[Music]
so the money situation itself like women
get paid less than a dollar to the to
the man right but how do you know how do
you know that we're paid less because
we're women
if you're going to be an engineer like
there's not a lot of female the only but
even when you come to sports right the
only sport that is paid the exact same
money though no but I'm saying yes
that's because respectfully I know men
are better than women at sports sorry
I'm sorry
I'm sorry you're probably you you
specifically you're probably better than
most men but in general like most men in
the NDA can dunk WNBA can't and they and
they get paid more because they make
more money like the like women's NCAA
has been at a loss for years they don't
even make money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's I don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog the
man because every time you're watching
no like no idea
if I really want to watch a women's game
like I would watch a women's game like
that when it gets to like
certain levels like final semi-finals I
like I watch it but like
this is like and I'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
I was a woman I would [ __ ] hate men
I'd be like the feminist like slew them
but it's like it is like it is always
with like on an individual level what
we're gonna do is the people
just that
that you're saying you know I mean and
that is why there's those women groups
because of these situations it's so hard
for us to get jobs and then you add race
into it you add where you live ethnicity
all these things are so difficult so
yeah there are only women in clubs there
are only women gyms oh no there's not
meant because there's dirty old men who
went in the corner that comes into that
yeah but there's this things all put in
for women because for so many years
they've been
devaluated
how are we devalued we got to stay at
home and not work that [ __ ] sounds
awesome
but I'm saying like like like even even
the women but that was only cute that
came from like the war days where the
women had jobs in the war and then the
men came home and then they took those
women's jobs so then they got put back
in the home of now you have to live well
historically men had to fight in war so
how can we say we are we never had to
fight in wars
and also
let's talk about the pay Gap like the
reason that women are paid more than
women is because they pick industries
that make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more Choice the the pay Gap
is bigger because men choose like
professions with objects or women's
women choose professions with peoples
wait wait wait shout them out I will
later no but I'm asking like like our
automatic gut reaction is always that
like it's about male and female
but like how do you know it's not just
the industries we pick
an official industry a lot of industry
is a big thing
no go ahead I've spoken my my part yeah
I agree with her a lot I can't lie um I
feel like there's just a lot of factors
like you can say okay cool like men get
to go work and the women get to stay at
home and it's all fun but it's not all
fun and games a lot of those women are
abused they're treated like crap like
that they're controlled but why is that
your immediate like like I just don't
understand why that's your immediate gut
reaction is to say like they're at home
because they're controlled and they're
abused and all that stuff you know what
I'm asking is that is that your your
view on men it's just that do you think
I think the majority of men are like
abusing their women no but I think a lot
of those women are unhappy and it comes
from the old school days like where
they're actually suppressed and they're
kind of taught they're brought into that
tradition and it just continues where a
lot of those women actually are unhappy
and they would like to speak out and do
vomiting like if your mom raised you
like yo don't chase [ __ ] from no man
like you would move completely most
different cultures though different
cultures
she says the oldest coach I'm like bro
it depends on he had been raised by life
some families invite this something but
that's right that's where Xenia was like
that's where race comes into ethnicity a
lot of those things come like they're
big factors like we can all talk about
the positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy a lot of those who are
fake
why is
yours we don't but that is yeah but you
also see it from one
um perspective woman in a white world in
America so you only see one way so you
don't really see how the other different
ethnicities different cultures have
completely their women have to stay at
home that is you're saying that's really
cool but as women we're starting to we
want to be CEOs we want to be pushing
where we're at the equal of men and this
is what she's saying as a young woman is
saying like actually no I would like to
pay I would but do I have the
opportunities to make that same money
but I'm saying like like if that's true
like why in the countries where women
have more Choice than ever is the pay
Gap bigger so you can you can make a
list of countries right where women are
the most depressed and the least
depressed and the pay Gap grows when
women have more choice because of the
industries they pick but a lot of men so
I'm not even talking about other factors
I'm just talking about like male and
female go ahead sorry a lot of men do
run those Industries though that
determine those pays like a lot of men
even like they're very biased in terms
of like even internal promotions and
stuff within companies but they can't
change a pay grade like of like yo
you're a man
but I'm saying to to offset that we have
quotas so there are like I worked in
copier sales for two years that's a very
male dominated industry it's [ __ ] it's
awful oh my God
and they couldn't get women to stay
because it was terrible like it's a like
those those jobs are working 80 90 hours
a week my dad worked 80 hours a week my
whole life do you want I don't want to
work 80 hours a week I don't know many
girls that do there's a lot of women
that actually are out there like even in
a lot of countries like they're working
a lot they're working at two free jobs
just to keep it yeah but I'm saying but
I'm saying if that's true then why in
the countries where they have the most
choice to do that do less women
like something like what's the
difference so I'm saying like like you
go to the countries where women have
more Choice an opportunity to do those
things and they choose not to why if
women want to I think it's just a lot to
do with like history as well though like
you're stuck in a phase so maybe I I'm
not saying women don't make there's a
lot of women that make stuff harder for
themselves like we do all have a choice
but there's a lot of circumstances that
dictate that like we can even go back
like I don't know this is relevant but
it actually makes sense to me like the
whole Molly made like we all have 24
hours in a day like we actually don't
have the same 24 hours in a day like
everyone's circumstance
there's so many factors that come into
that like like culture like everything
like it's just the opportunities don't
actually get given like as much as you
think they do it's not like a gender
thing for sure like it's not just it's
not just race though like there's a lot
of Caucasian women
disability like there's a lot of like
other factors but I'm saying like just
pure gender like
over a man because you saw the name if
they had the same skills like well and
the other question is like why aren't we
rallying like we'll talk about CEO and
power positions but why aren't we
talking about women not wanting to be
things like garbage collectors plumbers
like all the hard jobs in the in the
military like it's always like like
that's what I'm saying we only complain
there's a lot of women in the military
but they get treated like absolute [ __ ]
they don't get paid you know women
Brothers though you know I don't know
any man I don't know any women plumbers
but I know a Navy person and he they
disrespect women like nothing they treat
them like [ __ ] and he's a high-ranking
person
and so it's hard to be this but then
there's also it's like okay there's not
men beauticians like there's this job
there's just gender jobs that just like
uh we're trying to break off why can't
there be a woman planner why can't there
be a man who does my eyelashes there's
not enough man being like yo I want to
do eyelashes and it's like
this whatever changes
but this is why like I'm going back to
the same question where it's like we're
complaining about inequality when it
doesn't like benefit us